day two of confirmation hearings for
supreme court nominee katanji brown
jackson began just a short time ago
senators on the judiciary committee are
questioning the federal appeals court
judge about her record and approach to
judging jackson has vowed to defend the
constitution and remain independent on
the high court nicole killian is
covering the hearing force nicole good
morning to you how tough do you think it
could get for the judge today
as you can see over my shoulder
questioning just got underway this
morning republicans are drilling down on
judge jackson's views on everything from
court packing to crime while democrats
are trying to keep the focus on her
record
would you like to comment at the outset
of those who are looking for a label
what your position is on judicial
philosophy i am acutely aware that as a
judge in our system
i have limited
power
and
i am trying in every case
to stay in my lane democrats kicked off
the second day of judge katanji brown
jackson's confirmation hearings as
republicans pressed for a thorough
review
do you believe
the individual right to keep and bear
arms is a fundamental right it came
after a day of introductions thank you
for this historic chance
to join the highest court the nation's
first black female supreme court nominee
opened her confirmation hearing
acknowledging her family my parents
taught me
that unlike the many barriers that they
had had to face growing up
my path was clearer and affirming her
commitment to the law i have been a
judge
for nearly a decade now and i take that
responsibility and my duty to be
independent very seriously
i decide cases from a neutral posture
missouri's josh hawley ticked through
several of jackson's sentencing
decisions claiming she was too lenient
on sex offenders a claim that has been
refuted by the white house and
democratic lawmakers i'm not interested
in trapping judge jackson i'm not
interested in trying to play gotcha i'm
interested in her answers answers that
she is starting to give today speaking
about how seriously she takes those
offenses and what she tells offenders
that you are contributing
to child sex abuse
and then i impose a significant sentence
and
all of the
additional restraints
that are available in the law
senators are getting 30 minutes apiece
to question judge jackson which means
she could be in the hot seat for up to
11 hours before she has to do this all
over again tomorrow
nicole thank you very much we'll be
following it